i'm really scared of spiders i didn't
know really what to expect there was
going to be a scene
where they were going to dangle a spider
on my shoulder and so they did all these
tests with these little baby tarantulas
just so i could get sort of adjusted to
it they put up my leg and my shoulder as
well that was horrible i've never told
anyone this but i hated that requirement
set i got really claustrophobic in it
and hot because it's just like really
hot we had to wear those shoes every
time we stepped in picks it was all
mirrors and then towards the end it was
just like too many people in one room
like it got a bit hysterical anything
that really sort of was a bit
frustrating was the fact that
communication is obviously quite
difficult the scene where she gives him
the detention was uncomfortable for me
you think it's just it's just acting but
afterwards it wasn't i thought oh put
yourself inside that person for those
scenes and then you walk away from
things
those people to be given that amount of
power is is not right